well outside of that debate between
those who say the press is too
adversarial and must be curbed and those
who say well yes the presses can't
anchor isn't impossible but we just have
to suffer that mandra's of freedom
outside the spectrum of that debate
which constitutes virtually the entire
mainstream discussion virtually the
entire discussion but outside the debate
there is another position the other
position challenges the factual
assumption that's taken for granted in
the debate according to this alternative
view the media do indeed fulfill a
societal purpose but a very different
one their societal purpose is to
inculcate and defend the economic and
social and political agenda of the
privileged groups that dominate the
domestic society and they do this in all
sorts of ways they do it by selection of
topics by distribution of concern by the
way they frame issues by filtering of
information by emphasis and tone by
simple fabrication sometimes but
crucially by the bounding of debate to
make sure that it doesn't go outside of
certain limits the bounding both in the
news columns and in the opinion columns
because of course the news columns
themselves embody all sorts of
assumptions and ideological
presuppositions and so on to the
according to this alternative view to
the extent that there is a liberal bias
it serves primarily to bound thinkable
thought that is to instill the
unchallengeable assumptions which in
fact reflect this rather narrow elite
consensus so the liberal bias performs a
real function it says thus far and no
further
as far as you can go and I go as far how
far I go is still accepting the basic
presuppositions as unchallengeable now
within those bounds there's ample
controversy and it reflects the tactical
divisions among elites over how to
achieve generally shared aims but these
limits are very rarely transcendent so
the media thus function in accordance
with what my co-author Edward Herrmann
and I have called a propaganda model and
a recent book that's another view
well the propaganda model has a lot of
predictions as a lot of predictions
about how the press is going to behave
but it also has a further prediction the
further prediction is that no matter how
well confirmed the propaganda model is
it cannot be taken seriously and
therefore must be effectively excluded
from mainstream discussion and that
actually follows from the model itself
the reason is that the model if you
think it through the model rejects
certain principles that are serviceable
to power that is it falls outside the
spectrum defined by the presupposition
that the media are adversarial and
cantankerous perhaps excessively so now
that presupposition is a useful one it's
serviceable to the interests of
established institutions to believe that
what you're reading is actually
criticism if it's in fact support that's
a technique it's a sophisticated
technique of indoctrination and of
course it's very serviceable to the
media themselves it's nice to think that
Europe you know pride yourself on being
an independent that courageous adversary
of power and since those assumptions are
serviceable they're going to be upheld
according to the propaganda model and no
serious challenge will be permitted
so that prediction indeed is very
readily confirmed the propaganda model
has never taken seriously it can't be
considered notice that the propaganda
model has a rather disconcerting feature
to it plainly as a matter of logic it's
either valid or invalid if it's invalid
you can dismiss it if it's valid you
must dismiss it because it's saying the
wrong thing so one way or another it's
got to be dismissed by its very nature
and notice the truth is no defense it's
very much like the traditional doctrine
of seditious libel the doctrine that
it's you can't it's libelous it's crime
to criticize state authorities because
that undermines power it's a doctrine
that runs up to pretty modern times and
truth was never a defense against
Odysseus libel in fact truth simply
heightened the enormous and nor
of the crime of calling authority into
disrepute and the same is true here well
of course the basic the basic questions
are factual are the standard assumptions
correct that is is it true that the
press is independent cantankerous
adversarial maybe excessively so or are
the assumptions of the propaganda model
correct that's factual question and
that's the main topic but I'm barely
going to be able to get into it but
before though I won't try to really you
know know no hope in a few minutes of
providing real evidence one way or
another let me just talk a little bit
about that the way you would deal with
this problems of methodological
questions first notice three comments
one the propaganda model has a certain
prior plausibility to it that is if
you'd simply accept uncontroversial
free-market assumptions quite fun
controversial assumptions about how
society works you're led almost
automatically to the propaganda model
you can see that pretty simply simply
ask yourself what the media are now
notice here I'm talking about what some
might call the agenda-setting media the
media that set the frame that others
adapt to and that's pretty narrow group
it's primarily the New York Times in the
Washington Post and the three television
channels and a couple of others it's not
much else those set the framework that
everyone else pretty well adapts to
within anything like the mainstream so
we're talking about the agenda-setting
media and ask yourself what they are
well what they are is very large
corporations in fact they are integrated
with often owned by even larger
conglomerates now like other businesses
they have a product that they sell to a
market the market is advertisers other
businesses and the product is audiences
the media don't finance themselves on
their audiences in fact the audiences
are usually a loss the more you
subscribe the more the newspaper loses
money and of course the television set
you know they might anything when you
turn it
they make their money from advertisers
advertising rates go up if you have a
the right kind of audience and certainly
a relatively privileged audience raises
advertising rates so what the media are
just as an institution is major
corporations selling relatively
privileged audiences to other businesses
well what would you expect to come out
of such a system you expect to come out
something that reflects the interests of
the sellers the buyers and the product
wouldn't be very surprising in fact it
would be amazing if it weren't true
quite apart from that there are many
other things pressing in the same
direction there are after all centers of
power in the society the state you know
the corporate sector others and they can
impose punishments for things go wrong
and we will offer rewards if things go
right you gain by adapting to them it's
less costly and so on
furthermore the top managerial positions
in the media editors and columnists and
so on if you make it into those
positions you're part of the privileged
elite part of the very top in fact
though that's where your associations
are and your perceptions and your
friends and people you play golf with
and everything else and it wouldn't be
very surprising again if you reflected
the same interests and it goes on if you
think through I wouldn't discuss this in
our book a lot but if you think through
it there are just many pressures which
lead immediately to the assumption that
the propaganda model is highly plausible
even without any evidence it's at least
it's got prior plausibility in fact it
would be rather surprising if it weren't
true on uncontroversial assumptions
that's point one point two is it has a
lot of elite advocacy that's what I
started with pointing out that it
represents a position that intellectual
elites have thought the media ought to
serve and the whole system of Education
and so on ought to serve that's the
position since the 17th century probably
the dominant position it's necessary to
manufacture consent for the general good
because of the stupidity the average man
and so on we have to put aside these
democratic dogmatism so we have a
position
has prior plausibility and elite
advocacy and a third point is it's
generally accepted by the public there's
very striking that the debate over the
media is determined by the intellectuals
and they're the most indoctrinated
sector of the society and for them the
only debate is over whether the meteor
to adversarial or not but there are
polls you ask the public what do you
think about the media and the poll
public generally thinks the media are
too conformist
and to subordinate the power in other
words they automatically accept
something like the propaganda model so
here we have three facts a position that
has prior plausibility a lead advocacy
and rather general public support well
that doesn't prove that it's valid of
course but it does suggest that it ought
to be part of the discussion it's not
part of the discussion exactly as the
model predicts now by now turning to the
factual matter there are by now
thousands of pages of documentation
detail close documentation on the
propaganda model and it's been tested in
just about every conceivable way
subjected to the harshest tests we can
think of I think by now it's one of the
best confirmed theses of the social
sciences if there's any serious
challenge to it I've never seen it it's
generally just ignore it or else
caricature so what you have is this very
well confirmed thesis not proven very
well confirmed thesis no serious
challenge to it to my knowledge it has
prior plausibility the model is
plausible and uncontroversial
assumptions advocated by elites
generally supported by the public but
it's not part of the discussion exactly
in accord with its predictions it's off
the agenda well the next task and the
interesting one would be to look at
actual details as I say there's plenty
of things you can look at in print and
be thousands of pages and more coming
out and I'm not gonna I almost hesitate
to give examples because they're
misleading any set of examples will be
misleading because I think its
predictions are essentially universally
confirmed with only statistical error so
giving examples is misleading because
you might argue plausibly that the
examples are not properly selected
I'd be a reasonable response and that's
why I have to look at a range of tests
to make sure they are properly selected
like let the people who think that the
media are adversarial pick their own
grounds
that's the harshest test that the model
can face so let them pick the
groundswell they've picked their grounds
things like the coverage of the Tet
Offensive and so on and it turns out
that everything you go to Tet Offensive
Watergate iran-contra hearings you take
a look at them the itch they show
precisely the subservience of the press
to establish power compare paired
historical examples I mean history
doesn't run controlled experiments but
it runs things that are reasonably close
for example you find similar times and
similar periods when at that you can
find atrocities of roughly the same
scale carried out by official enemies or
by ourselves and our clients and look at
the comparative coverage or good deeds
like elections carried out by our
clients and our enemies and look at the
comparative coverage all of these tests
and in fact every other one I've ever
been able we've ever been able to
concoct leads to the same conclusion the
propaganda model is quite valid as a
very good first approximation to the way
the media function